[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good evening, everybody.
We're going to go ahead and
start the after-screening panel
discussion.
Note to self, never agree to
be the first person that speaks
after a screening of Dawnland.
But we're going to
go forward anyway.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
My name is Shelly Lowe.
I am Navajo.
I'm from Ganado, Arizona.
I'm the executive director of
the Harvard University Native
American Program.
I want to thank everybody
for joining us this evening.
I hope that you
enjoyed the film.
I want to thank Adam Mazo,
who is here with us tonight,
who essentially made the film
with the Upstander Project.
And I also want to think
Professor Bruce Duthu--
I know he's trying
to hide all the way
in the back of the room--
who co-produced
the film and served
as an advisor on the film.
Professor Duthu is at
Dartmouth University.
I also want to thank
Tracy Rector who
created the little postcards
that you have on your chairs.
This image is of
traditional wetu
that the Native American
students and alumni
built in Harvard Yard in 2009.
And we had these specifically
made for our screening
tonight here at Harvard.
I'm going to introduce
the panelists,
and I'm going to turn it over to
our moderator, Professor Robert
Anderson.
We will have some reflections
from our panelists,
and then we will
open up the floor
to questions for the panelists.
We'll do that for
about 20, 25 minutes.
We will have to end
after that, but we
encourage anyone
who wants to come up
to speak to the
panelists afterwards,
to please come forward and
talk to them after that.
Robert Anderson, our
moderator tonight,
is a professor and director
of the Native American Law
Center at the University
of Washington School of Law
and is the Oneida Indian Nation
Visiting Professor of Law
at Harvard Law School,
where he teaches annually.
He teaches primarily
in the areas
of American Indian law,
water law, natural resource
law, and property law.
He is the co-author
and member of the board
of editors of Cohen's Handbook
of Federal Indian Law.
He is also co-author of
Anderson, Berger, Frickey,
and Krakoff, American Indian
Law, Cases and Commentary.
He spent 12 years
as a staff attorney
for the Boulder-based
Native American Rights Fund,
also known as NARF, where he
litigated major cases involving
Native American sovereignty
and natural resources.
He was one of the two attorneys
who opened NARF's Alaska office
in 1984.
From 1995 to 2001, he served
as a political appointee
in the Clinton administration
under Interior Secretary Bruce
Babbitt, providing
legal and policy advice
on a wide variety of Indian law
and natural resource issues.
Bob was the co-chair
of the Obama transition
team for the Department of
the Interior in 2008 and one
of five members of the National
Commission on Indian Trusts
Administration and Reform.
He is a member of the
Bois Forte Band of Ojibwe.
Esther Anne, who
you saw in the film,
is Passamaquoddy,
part of the Wabanaki,
the people of the dawn,
from Pleasant Point.
And she joined the
Edmund S. Muskie School
of Public Service in 2003,
engaging young people
in foster care to ease their
transition into adulthood.
Esther had the honor of having a
critical role as a Muskie staff
person and a Wabanaki
community member
in the creation and
establishment of the Maine
Wabanaki-State
Child Welfare Truth
and Reconciliation Commission
and Maine-Wabanaki REACH.
She is now deeply engaged
in the implementation
of the Commission's
recommendations
through the lens of restorative
justice and decolonization.
Esther earned a master's
degree in social work
at the University of
Maine in Orono in 1977.
1997, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
And has served as adjunct
faculty to the school.
Currently, she facilitates
the tribal-state Indian Child
Welfare Act
Workgroup and creates
products for tribal-state
collaboration and best child
welfare practice with
native children and families
through the Capacity
Building Center for Tribes.
Esther is working
toward reclamation
of Wabanaki territory, language,
and ways of knowing and being.
She enjoys making art,
outdoor activities,
and spending time with the
young people in her life.
Adam Mazo is
co-director and producer
of First Light and
Dawnland, which
airs nationally on Independent
Lens on PBS this November 5th.
His hour-long film
Coexist, which
was nominated African Movie
Academy Award in 2011,
aired on public television
and WORLD channel.
He is co-founder and director of
Upstander Project, a filmmaking
and learning
collaborative which helps
bystanders become upstanders
through film and learning
resources.
His films and their
companion resources
are the cornerstone of Upstander
Project's flagship program,
the Upstander Academy.
The fourth annual addition is
being held in Boston in 2019.
Adam is a member
of the core faculty
at the week-long inquiry-based
summer professional development
experience.
Adam is originally
from Minnesota,
transplanted to Sarasota,
Florida for high school,
and later graduated from
the University of Florida.
He now lives in
Boston, Massachusetts
with his wife and family.
Ronald Niezen is the
Katharine A. Pearson
Chair in Civil Society
and Public Policy
in the Faculty of
Law and Department
of Anthropology at
McGill University.
He has conducted research on
an Islamic reform movement
in West Africa,
justice campaigns
in indigenous
communities in Canada,
and on the international
movement of indigenous peoples
in the United Nations.
His books include The
Origins of Indigenism,
Human Rights and the
Politics of Difference, Truth
and Indignation, Canada's Truth
and Reconciliation Commission
on Indian Residential Schools,
and a co-edited volume,
Palaces of Hope,
The Anthropology
of Global Organizations.
He is currently pursuing
a comparative study
of communication
technologies and the politics
of genocide claims.
And I will turn it over
to Professor Anderson.
- Thank you, Shelly.
Well, I want to
get to the audience
as soon as we can
for your questions.
But I think we
have to all agree,
it was a moving and
powerful movie and just
a tremendous work product
that you came up with
and tremendous experience
and work that you did.
I'm going to ask each of you to
just spend a couple of minutes
reflecting on the film
and on just what you
think about the issues.
And you're all either
directly involved
or have brought
experience in here.
And I'm going to
start on the far end,
so that we can let Esther
have the final word
before we move to
questions here.
So Ronald, I'm putting
you on the spot
here to talk a little bit about
just what you thought about it.
How does it compare to
what's happening in Canada
with your experience up there?
- Right, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm very pleased to be here
and to see so many people who
are interested in this film
and this important issue.
As I was watching
this film, I had
to think about it
comparatively, because I
spent about six years
studying Canada's Truth
and Reconciliation Commission
on Indian residential schools
when it first started
holding hearings in Winnipeg
in 2010 and all the
way to the presentation
of its final report
in December 2015.
And then looking at what
happened a little bit beyond.
And Canada's TRC was, of
course, on a much grander scale,
but the issues were
very much the same.
In Canada's TRC, I heard
the word cultural genocide.
In one memorable
meeting in Montreal,
former Prime
Minister Paul Martin
got a fairly solid
ovation when he
said, let's call
a spade a spade,
this was cultural genocide.
He was warmly applauded.
But I heard some people next to
me saying, no, it was genocide.
So the issues that were
raised were very similar.
What I saw here was
much smaller in scale.
And I was also particularly
interested to see
the social workers
give their testimony.
We had to sort of piece
together the chronology of who
had worked when and
to look at how--
actually, if you got
the chronology right,
you saw that some of
the attitudes of people
who represented the
social work community
had shifted a little
bit, from the women who
worked in the 1960s to people
who are still at the job.
One of the things that
Canada's TRC didn't do well,
which wasn't entirely its fault,
it had to do with the mandate,
was actually bring
clergy in, who
were the equivalent
of the social workers.
They were the ones who
represented the perpetrators.
They were the ones
who ran the schools.
And because there was a
compensation agreement that
accompanied the work of
the TRC, they strongly
disagreed with and didn't
like the accusations,
and they didn't like the
characterization of history.
Many of them stayed away.
They stayed away in droves.
And they had their own
sense of indignation,
which is one of the reasons
behind the title of my book,
Truth and Indignation.
That there was really
no reconciliation
between the people who ran
the schools and the people who
were often the survivors
of abuse in those schools.
One thing that I noticed was
missing from the film that
I'd be curious to hear about--
and perhaps Esther Anne could
fill this in--
was the families,
the families who
took in the children, the
non-indigenous families who
took in the children.
What were the attitudes
that they had?
Did they share the same
ideas as the social workers?
And what motivated them?
What were the
differences among them?
That's one of the pieces I would
have liked to see more about.
But on the whole, I
was very impressed
and moved by this documentary.
- Thank you.
Adam?
- I think you asked our
thoughts on the film.
I thought the film was great.
[LAUGHTER]
Are we done now?
- No, you can't
get off that easy.
So talk about the process.
Going into the communities,
there's always been a lot of--
well, you had Esther on your
team, which was a bonus.
But I hear complaints
all the time
about outsiders coming
into the communities
and taking information,
misusing it,
making a name for
themselves and leaving.
And then things are left
behind and not much happens.
- Thank you.
Thank you all for being here.
And Esther and I were smiling
at each other about your comment
about being on our team,
because we were working
alongside of each other,
but definitely there
were challenging
moments, particularly
when we showed the film to
Esther and a lot of the folks
that are in the film--
a rough cut-- a year ago?
A little more than a year ago.
And there were a lot
of things that they
felt could be improved and
changed, to say the least.
And so the final cut
that you saw tonight
is certainly considerably
different than what
they saw privately.
So our gratitude to Esther
and to so many Wabanaki folks
who invited us into the
process and welcomed us
into their homes.
And it's important to mention
that there's an entire team.
It's not just me.
My colleague Bruce, who's
here, co-producer on the film.
And then Mishy Lesser who's
here, our learning director,
author of the Dawnland
Teacher's Guide.
And then a number
of other colleagues
scattered around the country,
like Tracy Rector and Heather
Rae, Executive Producer.
There's a whole lot of us
working to make the film.
And a lengthy process of me
and Ben, the co-director,
explaining ourselves,
asking for consent,
and reaffirming consent over
and over and over again,
every room we were in,
every place we would go.
Talking about why we
were making the film
and trying to
acknowledge that we'd
come from a long line
of colonizers who've
come into Wabanaki communities
specifically and taken and not
given back, and vowing to
try to not be like that.
Hopefully we've
managed to do that.
That's been the
aspiration the whole time.
And we spent a lot of time
just being in community
and not filming and trying to
be clear about our intentions
and trying to understand
what our impact would be,
even when those two
didn't necessarily align.
There are plenty of times where
I stuck my foot in my mouth
and said stupid things,
and Esther called me
out on those I think 100%
of the time probably.
Maybe 99%?
[LAUGHTER]
- I wasn't the only one
that called you out.
- She wasn't the only
one that called me out.
That's for sure.
So we made plenty of
mistakes along the way
and tried to remain
committed to making sure
that the ultimate goal
was that this film would
be useful for Wabanaki people
and honor the truth-telling
that they did.
Not just in the
film, but there's
so many other folks who
told their truths who
are not in the film, but you
can see them in the archives.
I think particularly,
it's heartening
to see that there's
a recognition
of the importance of
truth-telling and the courage
that it takes.
I think particularly after
the events of yesterday,
maybe there's even
more awareness
in our society about
how difficult it
is to tell the truth in the
face of tremendous power,
patriarchy, and colonialism.
So we hope that
Dawnland can contribute
to that dialogue of
holding up truth-telling
and how incredibly
difficult it is
when you're talking
about some of the most
horrific or the most traumatic
memories that a person can have
and sharing those on the record.
So it's about the Wabanaki
people, ultimately.
That's what this film is
about and who it's for.
- Thanks.
Esther?
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
My name's Esther Anne.
I am Wabanaki, a people of
the place where the sun first
looks our way.
I'm Passamaquoddy from
Sipayik, or Pleasant Point--
the people who spear pollock.
And I live with
Penobscot people,
place of the white rocks.
Thank you for having
me here tonight.
This is kind of too close.
It's interesting.
I was sitting here thinking
about what you said
about people having a lack--
we have such a level of distrust
and mistrust, legitimately so.
But I was just talking to the
students at the lunch today,
and I was remarking
about how I think
it seems like in our
tribal communities,
people were more leery
of the commissioners
and the commission and that
agreement with the state
than they were of
the filmmakers.
Really, I think people
were way more open.
And we had some
conversations a couple times
about the different worldview
that native people have as
opposed to these filmmakers
that are coming in.
And how generous and open
especially Wabanaki people are.
And how when they
would invite these guys
into their homes or to go
elver fishing or to go hunting
or to go blueberry raking, I
don't think that they really
necessarily understood
at the same level
that Adam and Ben did, that
these guys were always working.
They were always on.
And it was in Aroostock
County when I invited them up
to my campsite, and Ben
drags out the camera.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
Put that away.
And he's like, no,
I'm always working.
And I said, then you need
to explain that to people.
Because native people don't
necessarily think that way.
But it turned out all right.
I would really like these
guys to document your process
that you went through and
how you change from when
you started to when you ended.
Because I think you,
too, have changed a lot.
I've witnessed a transformation
in your level of understanding.
- In a negative way?
- Your sense of humor is
a little bit better now.
[LAUGHTER]
You can take a joke.
- Only slightly.
- You're a little
bit more assimilated.
You're late for things.
No, I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
So I don't know what
else to comment on.
I think it would
be better if there
were things you wanted
me to comment on,
because I could
talk way too long.
- Should we respond to
what Ronald mentioned?
- Yeah.
Go ahead, yeah.
- Did you want to say
anything about [INAUDIBLE]??
- I would say that it might
be missing from the film,
but it's not missing
from the archives.
So there are
statements from people
who were provided foster,
were resource families
and foster families,
siblings and parents
that took children in.
So they're there,
but I don't know
why they didn't [INAUDIBLE].
- And in terms of the film,
we made a conscious decision
to not focus on non-native
people for the most part.
We felt that the process
of the commission
was pretty important
and at least necessarily
needed to involve a lot
of the non-native people.
But when it came to the
non-native foster families,
obviously their story is
important and relevant,
but we just felt like, for
the purposes of the film,
the focus should be on the
commission and the people
sharing their truth with
the commission, particularly
Wabanaki people.
- Good, yeah.
- You could probably make 10
films with everything you have.
- Well, I think I'd
like to open it up
to the audience for
people to comment.
And Bruce Duthu's back there.
I don't know if Bruce would
like to say a few words.
Maybe not, and that's
why he's not up here.
But just generally, I've
observed and followed
the Indian Child Welfare
Act since it was passed,
just before I started
practicing law for NARF.
And I've followed
the implementation
and worked on it.
And I see an incredible
retrenchment nowadays.
And I saw your
statistics at the end
about the continuing
problems with placements.
And we've got very conservative
groups, like the Goldwater
Foundation, bringing lawsuits
to try to set aside the statute.
And fortunately, we've got
great groups of native lawyers
around the country that
are working together
to put this together.
But even so, it's
a constant battle.
And we saw what we
confront yesterday,
or at least my feeling
was, there it is.
And so it's a struggle.
But getting the story out like
this is incredibly important.
And I've just noticed that
it's the younger people that we
have to educate--
the social workers,
the younger people.
And for them to be able
to experience something
like this when they're
learning about what
they're going to do in the
future is incredibly important.
So I'm hoping that somebody will
come up to the microphone here.
So if you want to come up and
ask a question or comment,
thank you.
- A red flag went up in my head
when I saw stolen children.
People don't get stolen.
They either get kidnapped, or
if they're in an abusive family
recently, they get removed.
So that really had
me thinking about,
who is shaping the
narrative here?
And so I'm wondering,
what was the process
like of the filmmakers with
interviewing those Indian folks
about the kidnapping,
which implies
a crime that was committed?
As opposed to stolen, which
devillifies the crime?
- What was that last bit?
Sorry.
As opposed to stolen, which--
I just want to make sure.
- Devillifies-- it makes
it not like a villain.
It makes it smoother.
It makes it not a crime.
- Sugarcoat, maybe?
- Good question, thank you.
- Glad I don't
have to answer it.
[LAUGHTER]
- So in terms of the--
what was your name, by the way?
- I didn't give it.
- OK.
In terms of the interviews-- you
probably noticed in the movie,
for the most part,
the vast majority
of the interviews that
we show in the movie
are interviews
that were conducted
by the commission as opposed to
conducted by us as filmmakers.
We were present for a
lot of the statements,
but not all of them.
So we focused,
obviously, on selecting
who we would
include in the film,
but we weren't conducting
a lot of those interviews.
In terms of the language,
it's a great question.
I think we feel like stolen was
pretty strong and considerably
more aggressive than a
lot of the language that
is used among
academics when they
talk about this kind of thing.
And it's an important
conversation
to be having about
that language.
And I'm going to keep
thinking about it, because
of your question.
So I'm grateful to you for that.
- One thing that--
the Upstander, they
have a teacher's guide.
And they talk about
the connection
between stealing children
and stealing the land.
So maybe that had
something to do
with them choosing that word,
because it's more analogous
or whatever.
But I don't know.
I'm just guessing.
- Should we ask Mishy to come
up and tell us a little bit more
about it--
- Yeah, we could ask Mishy.
She could probably--
- --since she's
the author of it?
- Oh, OK.
There's a comparative
dimension to this too,
in that in Australia, the
children who are forcibly
removed from their families
and placed in foster homes
are referred to collectively
as the stolen generation.
These words, these
terminologies,
have a tendency to leap across
continents and get picked up.
- So my colleague Mishy Lesser's
the co-creator of the Upstander
Project and the author of
the Teacher's Guide and is
at the microphone.
- Thank you.
I was going to say,
similarly, that there
is a lot of scholarship
that talks about taking.
But the compelling
question that overarches
the whole educational endeavor
that accompanies this film
is, what is the relationship
between the taking of the land
and the taking of the children?
And so land dispossession--
And here we are in
a setting that's
devoted to teaching
and learning.
We could map connecting the
dots between land dispossession
and the taking of the
children across the centuries.
And our goal by teaching
this film with the Dawnland
Teacher's Guide is so
that students come away
knowing how to
wrestle with evidence
and begin to create an argument
to answer that question.
- Next question.
- Thank you for the film
and thank you for being here
tonight.
My question was about
the children reuniting,
who are now adults,
with their families,
and how they found them.
Some of them seemed to have
known their birth names.
And I just didn't
know how they--
after they had been taken
into foster families,
were they still in touch
with their families?
Or did it come up in the
process of still wondering
who their birth parents were?
- I think all of that.
I think all the
stories were so varied.
I provided a statement
to the commission.
I didn't sit in on
any of the statements,
but I sat in on a lot of
circles in our communities
that weren't
archived or recorded,
and I've heard
stories like that.
Even some of the folks who
have shared their story--
we have siblings that
are talking about things,
and they haven't talked
to each other about it.
So that happens a
lot, the silence.
- Hello.
My name is Jelani.
I'm a graduate student in
history here at Harvard.
I had a question about the
Secretary of State's statement
towards the beginning of the
film about the governor's
concern about the possible
requests for reparations.
And I was wondering
if reparations,
monetary or otherwise, were
ever part of the discussion
with the state government.
And if not, why that was
not part of the strategy.
Thank you.
- Reparations was a topic
that the organizers--
the group of us that created
this commission process--
we talked about
reparations a lot.
And even when we were
organizing the commission
and we decided to ask the
tribal governments and the state
government to sign on, we were
real conscious about not saying
that that was our end goal.
And we also didn't ask
them to give any money.
I mean, they didn't
have to do anything.
We were going to bear
that burden on our own,
because we wanted to increase
our chances of them saying yes.
So reparations, we had a lot
of discussions about this.
And within our group and
within tribal communities,
people have all kinds
of different views
about reparations, as they
do about what is justice
and how forgiveness
comes into that
and what restoration looks
like and repairing of harm.
And we had folks that
were really victimized,
like Denise, my sister-in-law
that's on the film.
And she's like,
there's no amount
of any kind of reparation
that could give me back
what has been taken from me.
And then you had other folks
that have a different view
and believe in reparations--
structural reparations,
monetary reparations.
So it's really personal.
But that was the biggest fear
that the people at the state
had.
Because they know
that a reparation
comes when you have
to repair something.
So they knew that
something had happened.
And that's what
they were afraid of.
So, yeah, when Matt was chosen
to be on the commission--
the governor of the state--
he was not happy.
He was pretty scared about it.
But the commission, I
think that they must
have dealt with the issue, too.
But I wasn't privy to their
process or their deliberations.
I was anxious to see their
report and recommendations
like everybody else.
So I'm sure it comes
up all the time.
Because even for people to
acknowledge that there was harm
is one thing.
But for them to take that step.
And just like
watching this film,
you got an emotive response.
It felt horrible, right?
You feel bad.
You feel whatever.
But if you go home
and nothing changes,
then what was the point?
We have to motivate,
and we have to start
living our lives differently.
We have to start
looking through things
through a lens of colonization,
which means we have to undo it.
And that's something
different for all of us.
So we can't leave
here and be the same.
- And if we, as white folks,
seriously look at reparations,
we have to look at, what
is it that we have taken?
And it's the land.
- It's a powerful film.
Thank you.
I have an artistic
question, which
is it felt like there was
a very powerful moment
before we went to the
scene at the fire at night.
And what was the
decision that went
into including that
as the final scene
and ending on the words
of the Secretary of State?
- Tell her Sandy
hates that scene--
- Thank you.
- --because they didn't
listen to Sandy White Hawk,
because she didn't
like that ending.
- We had a lot of
conversations about that scene.
It made a lot of
sense to us to end
at the fire, because so much
started and would start and end
at the fire each day, with
the commission doing its work.
But also, at least my very
minimal understanding,
in Wabanaki communities
the fire is really central.
So it made sense.
We played around with the
idea of starting the film
and ending the film there,
and it just felt like a moment
to be at the fire
as a viewer and sit
with all of the feelings that
you've had watching the film.
And then also hear that--
we hope-- that epic line
from [INAUDIBLE] at the end--
reconciliation,
that's the long road.
And in terms of the last voice,
the last voice is the music.
It's the singers,
singing the song.
I mean, sometimes the lights
come up and we miss that part.
But the last voice
is the music--
the Wabanaki people and
our Tuscarora composer
singing that song.
So yes, Matt gets
the last spoken word.
But we intentionally--
we learned
from many, many
viewings of the film
that if he didn't say
that, then we, as viewers,
didn't understand
that they were there
in the middle of the
night up until sunrise.
And that was an important
thing to understand.
Otherwise, people thought
maybe, OK, they were just there
after dinner or whatever.
And that seemed
important to know.
- And that time of day is
a very significant time
for native people.
So it's a very sacred time.
So the scene's grown on me.
[LAUGHTER]
- Well, I have to
say, I thought,
what a white-man thing to say,
to look at his watch and say,
one hour, the sun will be up.
[LAUGHTER]
- But it's perfect.
It's perfect though, right?
- Oh, yeah.
Very much so.
- It shows.
- So let's have a
couple more comments,
and then we can
come up and mix--
- Are you saying we're
running out of time?
- I think Shelly
gave me the signal.
- Great.
Thank you very much for that.
That was incredibly moving,
incredibly powerful.
My question was
more about language.
And a lot of this
language came across
in a lot of the
interviews was people
talking about being beaten
for speaking your languages
and whatnot.
And I was wondering,
mostly for Esther Anne,
if you could talk a little
bit about the role of language
revitalization in, I suppose,
mostly in Wabanaki communities.
What's going on with that now?
- Yeah, I think Roger
Paul can speak to that.
In It, Rog.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- Yeah, Roger can you
come to the microphone?
Roger's at MIT right
now doing great things.
- Roger's a language teacher.
I was looking at him when
I was introducing myself
in my language.
I was looking over,
and he's going, yep.
So I know I did a good job.
[LAUGHTER]
- You did a good job.
- Thank you for that question.
I'm Roger Paul.
I'm a language teacher in
the Penobscot community.
I'm Passamaquoddy.
And it's always good to hear
Esther speak in the language.
I've been a teacher all
my life of the language.
It was before this
happened, when
I grew up on the reservation.
It was before the new Indian
Child Welfare system was.
I was the old Indian
Child Welfare system,
where my aunts and uncles
would shift us from reserve
to reserve in Canada
and the United States
to keep us from getting taken.
When I was six is
when I first had
to learn how to speak English.
So I still have trouble
with some English
and do say it backwards.
But language to our people--
and some of our
people do still speak.
And I make it my
job to make sure
that our children learn it.
Because when we speak in
our traditional language,
we're actually describing
the world around us
through the eyes
of our ancestors.
In those words,
you see the world
the way the ancestors saw it and
the way it was intended to be.
And if it's OK, one quick
story about why I teach two,
is in our language, the word for
dirt is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Now, in the English language,
when I learned the word dirt,
they used it to vilify,
to make something bad.
That oh, that's dirty.
Don't even think that.
That's something dirty.
But in our language, the
word is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
And when we break up that
word [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
it actually means "a
substance full of life."
And I asked an elder one
time, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
why do we say that
soil is full of life?
So he held up the soil
and said that in this hand
are the molecules
of our ancestors
that have sacrificed so much
for us to be here today,
and we need to honor that.
And all of creation
that lives comes
from molecules that give
new life in the earth.
And that's why we
call her our mother.
So from that day forward--
and I apologize for getting
emotional about this--
when that elder
taught me that, I
knew I could not
let our children
know just the English
definition of dirt.
They needed to know our
ancestors' definition.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[APPLAUSE]
- I was thinking during the film
about why the white people did
this to the native people.
And one of the things
that was discussed
was the fact that
the Carlisle Indian
School was seen as a progressive
innovation at that time.
And I call myself a
progressive, so I really
thought there's a struggle
there about why something
was seen as progressive
at one time,
when it was actually
destructive.
And so there's just something
to think about there, for me.
And also, there was
that anecdote about--
one of the social
workers said something
about how the apple
falls from the tree.
And it occurred to me
that that logic could also
mean that taking of
children from their families
might not apply only to natives.
It might apply to people
of different communities
and even to working
class whites that
are seen as having a
problematic family structure
or what have you.
So this is actually
part of something
bigger in the white society.
So that's--
- OK.
One more person is
waiting patiently.
- Thank you.
That was really powerful.
I've heard so much
about this film.
I'm a folklorist.
I'm based here, but I've done
a tremendous amount of work
with particularly the artists
in all four of the tribes
in Maine-- basket makers,
carvers, performers.
Several observations.
One, the question
about reparations,
I think that's particularly
important to Maine
because of the land
settlements in the 1980s.
And a lot of people
don't know about that
or haven't really put it in the
context of tribal lands now.
And I say that,
because last July,
I produced the
traditional folklife area
at the Lowell Folk Festival.
And we had, at the festival,
the Penobscot drummers.
And I had one of them
on my Foodway stage
doing fry bread, which people
have different opinions about.
But the point was,
people in the audience,
instead of talking about the
culture of the fry bread--
our theme was Brits--
they were asking him so many
questions about Indian life,
life on the reservation.
He's a young guy.
He didn't know about
the land settlements.
Well, that happened
a long time ago.
So I'm just pointing that
out, that connection.
And also to say that, in
general, a lot of the things
didn't surprise me at all that
people didn't show up for some
of the circles and meetings.
I'm not native, but I've
worked with the communities
for several decades and
have that level of trust.
But also, my job is
bringing some of the culture
out into the wider world.
So there's an opportunity
for learning on both sides.
Last question, you
mentioned the archives.
I just wondered where
your archives are from--
both the interviews, and
also, is the film outtakes,
is that archived anywhere?
And thank you, again.
- So the archives are all
stored at Bowdoin College
and they're available online.
You can read the written
testimony and there's audio.
And is there any video?
I don't think--
there's some video.
A lot of audio testimony.
So there's 150, I think.
About 90 from Wabanaki people
and the rest from non-natives.
So yeah, they're
there in the archives,
just all that ready to be
looked at and researched.
Rachel George from the Truth
Commission is back in Canada
getting a doctorate.
And she's doing some
follow-up research,
following up with
some folks that she
had met through the process.
And one of the things
we asked her to do
was to work on cataloging
those statements so
that we can know where to
look for different things.
Which is real important
to the ICWA Workgroup,
because we're always developing
tools to train caseworkers.
And it would be really
good if we can pull out
some of those excerpts
from caseworkers
saying this or that.
But we don't have the
time to get in there.
So she's going to catalog them
and do a thematic analysis,
so that'll be wonderful.
- And the outtakes
from the film--
there is a short
film that we produced
that you can go
and see at the Abbe
Museum in Bar
Harbor up in Maine,
for folks who are up that way.
And we're also hoping to put
together some other short films
that we'll put
out into the world
hopefully in the next
couple of years related
to people who we met through
the Truth Commission,
including Georgina,
the elder who
spoke up early on in the
film at Indian Township,
about sitting in the
bathtub full of bleach.
We filmed a tremendous
amount of footage with her,
and we're hoping to make
a short film about her
in the next year or so.
- OK.
Well, let's thank the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you have more questions,
come on up and visit.